wow
oh
so
so
how's it going sean cannell here and
welcome to this exclusive
training that is an inside look of our
inner
circle monthly online business coaching
program and is also being streamed the
first part
here on our think media podcast
channel i'm so fired up for today and
here's the topic do you want to learn
how to create a digital product
or an online course that earns you money
while you sleep
maybe you've been noticing that
stay-at-home moms are building
six-figure side businesses or corporate
professionals are quitting their
nine-to-five jobs
and they're packaging what they know
into a digital product and building
at-home businesses so they can spend
more time with their family
um if you want to learn how to tap into
what forbes told us that in just a few
years is going to be a billion dollar a
day industry
that's what today's session is all about
and in just a little while i'm going to
be introducing our guest
speaker our guest expert ali bjerk
who's going to be breaking down she's
i've seen no one better in the industry
for this topic today
of how to create a low-cost digital
product that not just changes lives
impacts people but also builds your
business in a major way so
here's kind of what we're doing this is
our inner circle program and
um for every single month we do a deep
dive training just like this
and in the first part we go through the
training and
is going to be breaking that down i have
an opening case study for you
but then during the second part we're
going to be doing some q a maybe some
hot seats and actually answering your
questions and that's in the members only
area so we have a lot of stuff
for happening today smash like if you're
fired out
up and shout me out where are you
watching from
um so that uh we can connect with you
i've got tony i've got melissa on the
think media team
in the comments connecting with you so
if you have any questions just let me
know
um and i'm excited to dive into this
training i want to thank you for being
here
um and really for investing in yourself
whether you're just kind of peering in
for the first time in the inner circle
or you've been a part of the inner
circle community for a while
you know myself on behalf of myself in
the think media team we just want to
thank you
for being someone that is a learner we
believe that lifelong leaders are
lifelong
learners and that this is one of the
best parts of our month because we can
become better
together you know warren buffett said
that the best investment you could ever
make is in yourself come on crypto's up
and crypto's down right now you know
what i'm saying anybody investing in
crypto
but the best investment you can make the
stock market's up amc to the moon or
it's going down
housing prices are all over the place
and of course we are wise investors but
the best investment you can make is in
yourself so i just want to thank you
shout out distractions grab a journal to
take notes i'm going to be taking notes
as ally's breaking down insights um and
so get ready to learn because again this
is a deeper dive
training that you want to set some time
aside really a good hour to really dive
into
this content i mean i want to open with
a quick story
and maybe you can remember headlines
like this
you know march 2020 where were you march
2020
hospitals on high alert for the deadly
coronavirus
you know i remember exactly where we
were we were here in las vegas a
lockdown started
um you know i've been an online business
owner besides a youtube content creator
we
at the time or business of 13 people
we've hired since then
um but we had been through a lot of good
seasons you know launched a best-selling
book
youtube secrets and our video ranking
academy program and it done a lot over
the last couple years maybe you know
heather taurus or omar
but march 2020 we felt like we got hit
by a truck and not just like in the same
way you were
but also in the same way for us that
month
we were negative thirty thousand dollars
on our p
l in our business you want to talk about
you know i was checking with my wife
who's our chief financial officer sonia
i was like wait up 30 she's like no
negative 30 30 000
negative and we had actually just hired
somebody maybe you know nolan over on
the
we just hired nolan we just hired tony
and we were like
what the heck and you remember all the
headlines all the stuff that's happening
business being shut down things are
being shut down you know people are
going into lockdown what's gonna happen
with this we're all like glued to the
news
and so i don't know where you were in
march 2020 but i know i was
you know in that moment of kind of like
uh
fear you know uncertainty what's gonna
happen
bracing for new life new routines and
now we've been through a year
and beyond of just crazy ups and downs
but i know for us one of the things we
did at the think media team and we
started to talk about was we thought we
really have two options right now
we can either go on defense or we can go
on offense
we can either shrink back in fear or we
can lean in in faith
you know i've heard fear stands for one
of two things
you know forget everything and run
or face everything and rise right
we decided to face everything in rise
even though we were scared to death
we decided to create instead of complain
right we decided to solve
problems and serve people instead of
sulk and specifically
we just started asking what can we do
what can we create and i want you to
think about that
what can you create to maybe change your
situation right now
what what what value can you create
entrepreneur solve problems
uh for a profit what value can you
create to serve people
and so the case study i wanted to share
with you was out of that crazy month
business is negative trying to figure it
out had a lot of things going for us but
was
thinking what can we do one of the
things that we did
was we created our youtube starter kit
now shout me out if you actually have
you know gotten our youtube starter kit
it's one of the most valuable things
we've ever created
um and it's a low-cost digital product
we created to serve our community
to help them get results faster it's a
power pack digital asset bundle
that short that will dramatically
shortcut your path to creating or
reviving your youtube channel
now if you read the title on youtube
where we're just streaming this first
part
we've we've sold it for different
amounts of money it's over 600
of value in terms of all the pieces of
it
it's normally 97 it's you know 47 right
now but we've also had sales on it at 27
we have the flexibility to do that
depending on
you know discounts or memorial day we
can say oh you know all these different
kinds of things
but out of creating this product
creating in the midst of chaos
we were able to generate five hundred
and forty six thousand five hundred and
eighty six
dollars so far now pretty crazy now
listen i'm not saying those results are
typical
you know what i mean like that's that's
pretty extraordinary some of them but
better maybe others worse
but i mean it's a crazy number and keep
in mind i think media is a team and we
got help
but like we created a low-cost digital
product
right that that helps and solves
problems and we launched it and then
we've learned a lot on the way so i just
want to share a couple lessons as we get
ready for like ali going deep
into how do you create a tiny offer
how do you create something that will
serve people what is
what is the elements that makes a tiny
offer successful versus not work
and this is one of the best things you
can create whether you are a youtuber
trying to create extra streams of income
a business owner trying to create
online income whether you already have a
high ticket offer or some kind of
coaching or consulting
and you want to create more leads and
lead into that
really this is one of the most essential
elements that no one's really talking
about
and here's just a couple lessons that i
learned though the first one is start
tiny
and that's what today's training is all
about get ready because ali is about to
bring the fire
what i mean by that is one of the first
things we did after i had built a six
figure income
reviewing tech affiliate marketing
youtube ads all that kind of stuff we
started to teach it in a program called
video ranking academy
thank god for it it's been amazing but
dear god it was stressful
why because it's an academy if you're in
it you know you're like there's a lot of
there's all these resources all these
videos
like it was like you know going from
zero to 100
real quick in terms of the amount of
stuff i had to build the amount of stuff
i had to create
the amount of slides in training and
videos when people think about
tapping into the e-learning industry the
online course industry
or creating a digital product different
those things are different but they're
kind of all one in the same thing you
know some kind of a digital online offer
sometimes you might get overwhelmed
you're like do i have to create a
university
you know do i have to create a whole
college here's the key and i learned
this from ali
start tightening like start small you
can create this in one day
you might be able to create this in a
few hours you might already have this
you just might need to pivot some things
already around what you've taught or
done or the book you wrote or are
writing or whatever
so start tiny because it's also
something you could get to the market
quickly so i look back
we like should have made the youtube
starter kit before we did video ranking
academy like in hindsight but you know
that's why you're here is to like learn
from my mistakes right and to be able to
go further faster
so that's kind of the first lesson
second lesson is scale with paid
traffic you know those are some big
numbers um and i want you to know
and ali is the expert at this but like
paid traffic was a huge part of that
like we have ad spend
the mistake a lot of people make in the
content creator mind spit set
is they lean only on organic traffic let
me build my subscribers
let me build up my views on youtube and
the thing with organic traffic is
typically
organic just means you're not paying for
it like a facebook ad or an instagram ad
or a youtube ad
it just means it's the long road i think
it's a good road i think it builds you
build a community
you serve people it actually builds
character it's a good road
but but paid traffic is modern marketing
like if you're not at least thinking
about what is my offer
what is my tiny offer and how am i going
to master
facebook ads instagram ads or who am i
going to work with to figure that out
this is modern marketing those who
ignore this and don't
learn this skill or work with the right
people
will at best survive and possibly
really disappear over the next decade
modern marketing is spending
is understanding that the best way to
reach people is this advertising
revolution
of facebook ads youtube ads and all that
kind of stuff
and you're gonna learn more about this
in this training that was the key to us
hitting numbers
and being able to get our tiny offer
into people's hands
and the third one is get help get help
too many entrepreneurs too many content
creators are out here
trying to reinvent the wheel man
someone's already done it so
so the key for us it's like i'm not
trying to reinvent the wheel on how to
figure out how to do tiny offers i'm
talking to the expert
ally right so so get help and
and think about how you can get help for
the skills necessary we always talk
about in our community
what skills do i need to survive and
thrive in the new economy what skills do
i need to dominate this next decade
and that's what today is all about with
this training that i hope you're ready
for and you're pumped
because we have just barely scratched
the surface and one of the things i've
learned with getting help
is that you can kind of jump out there
and do things
but about halfway through the starter
kit was when i discovered
ally bjerk and i started to realize oh
dang
we need to tweet this change that and in
hindsight i'm like there's so much stuff
we got to do
that's that's the speed of getting
connected to a coach right that's the
speed of getting connected with somebody
that can help you go further faster
so she's got a powerful training for us
but if you're just meeting ali bjerk
she's a visibility strategy coach and
consultant she's helped hundreds of
business owners create
the visibility strategies and marketing
plans behind growing a super profitable
business
for balanced and prosperous lives she's
a funnel expert
and she has taken her marketing agency
experience and used it to lead
entrepreneurs toward their goals
through her transformational programs
and her tiny offer
strategies but here's why i love
ally and uh i wore the same shirt that i
did in
in that photo that's that's kind of cool
it's almost like the exact same
okay uh if you're just listening on
audio that doesn't make sense listen
ali's amazing um because also anybody we
bring you
we have like kind of a a high filter
through our podcast through our inner
circle program through everything
where of course people have to pass the
business test
are they do they really have credibility
have they really built a real business
do their frameworks does their content
really good is it really worth your time
is it really going to serve you
but that's not our only test because
that's not the only definition of
success in our opinion
we really believe at think media we're
on a mission of 10 000
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world
on youtube i think that to do that you
need to build a business
around your youtube channel that's what
ally's going to show you to do with like
an offer your own products
scaling through ads those types of
things obviously she can't get into all
that but she's going to you know really
give us some crazy value
with the hour we have today but what i
love about ali is
is her values is that for her it's
family first for her
she really believes that you can build a
successful career
without you know losing your soul in the
process
and having those priorities so you don't
have to choose between your family
and your business and so i hope you're
pumped i'm pumped
uh for today can we welcome ally bjerk
to inner circle ally how's it going
oh my gosh i'm so excited to be here i
need you to like follow me around and
hype me up like that that was awesome
hey you got it wherever you are let me
know and actually
recently we uh we are in a mastermind
together we were recently in nashville
and we got to tour ramsey studios
a 300 million dollar building kind of
crazy got to hang out the entree
leadership team
and really spend some time again just
just we love to invest
in ourselves and learning and rubbing
shoulders with other people that are
doing big things and so anyways ali
without further ado i'm just so pumped
we're gonna hand it over to you for your
training i'm ready to take notes
and uh take it away awesome thank you
i'm so excited to get into this like
sean said we're gonna move fast
i have a hundred slides myself and i
think about an hour to get through them
so i hope you have notes ready i hope
you are
ready to jump in as much as i am i'm
gonna try to keep the comments
up and running so i can answer questions
as i go to but you guys are moving fast
as well so we'll see what we can do
but the topic of the training today is
how to quickly create your digital
product and discover how you can launch
those digital products in 1 100 of the
time
so like sean said with the very first
slide that we're jumping into here the
global e-course industry is predicted to
reach 325 billion with a b
by 2025 and i think that's even been
updated because you know with
coronavirus and everything happening in
our world
it's accelerated so now it's the point
of a billion dollars a day
365 billion if you can picture that a
billion dollars a day being spent in
this industry
so when i look at my numbers for what my
digital products have done in the last
you know
year or two at 2.2 million of revenue
that's like
not even a percent that's like not even
a half of a half a percent so
when we go into this training i really
want the growth mindset to
be where we're starting like this is
just the beginning of what's possible
for your business
the industry itself is in its infancy
and we're really only going to grow from
here so for people who are coming in and
they're like meh
there are people who are successful i
haven't launched anything yet it's too
late i haven't done it
i don't know what i would do there's too
much competition i want you to just wipe
all of that from your brain right away
just from the very you know the third
slide in
we're gonna have the abundance mindset
throughout this entire training and just
have that belief in your soul that this
is possible for you and we're going to
talk through exactly how to get it done
the problem with this industry however
is that people come
from two different mindsets they have
the the beliefs that
if you want to launch a digital product
and i even saw this in the comments
while sean was doing that awesome
intro like i don't know if i could
launch a course i'm here to listen but
i'm not ready to create a course we're
not talking about
creating an account academy or a
university or anything like that
these are tiny baby offers we're talking
about small digital products
it's not going to be a 997 dollar price
tag and
we're going to talk a lot about this
within the training is minimal viable
products so how do you get something to
the market as fast as possible
to let people actually tell you if they
want it and to pay for it while you're
creating it
because a lot of people even with these
997 courses they come to me and they're
like you know i spent months
creating this course and i built
everything that i thought people needed
and nobody bought it like i created it
and now it's just sitting on my hard
drive and
and no one's even you know it's like
collecting digital dust no one's even
paying attention to it
so there's that mindset there's also the
mindset of you know i'll just create a
membership like i'll just do a
reoccurring thing
put a little pricing on it like 27 37 a
month
but it's so much work to actually do
that to have the reoccurring
membership every single month with new
content you can get just
as you know much results monetarily with
reoccurring profit from a tiny offer
creating it once as you can with the
membership that every single month it's
like okay what what are we doing this
month how do we
not churn people how do we keep people
excited about the membership
you create it once and then you just
keep reselling it
so with this system it changed my entire
life
i was a service provider i was a funnel
builder social media strategist all the
things you guys heard the bio
and with doing this even in 2020 with
the chaos and you know i have three
little kids that i was
ultimately homeschooling for most of
2020 there was not a day that
passed in that entire year and the
entire social distancing and everything
else where i didn't make hundreds of
dollars passively
from the ads that i was running from the
products that i had created every single
day on my phone
looks like this just non-stop sales
because of the systems that i have built
because i have ads running we're not
going to ignore the paid media topic
because of course this isn't all profit
i'm going to show you my exact numbers
as we get into this
but having this system let me pay off
all my student loans
we paid off a minivan i actually bought
a new car with cash
since then we took vacations we bought
investment properties
and our life looks completely different
than it did before i just had
a product that had i mean it has ads
running to it right so it's ads
to products to sales all day long so
with this presentation
you're never going to have to think
about where your next sale is going to
come from or where your next client is
coming from
and i asked sean for a list of people
who might be attending today so that i
could dig into what types of businesses
you have and just make sure that this is
all really relevant and
it is from what he said you know even if
you are just starting or even if you
have a high ticket program or even if
you want to monetize a following that
you already have this
this entire system or this strategy is
really universal
so it's really cool to see how it works
inside of different businesses
so it's going to help you have space and
clarity and confidence and consistency
i know consistency is something i hear a
word all the time that people are like i
wish i could just
have consistency in my content in my
sales in you know predictability of from
my business
and building this type of structure and
this foundation behind your business is
really what's going to help you get that
done
it's also going to help you get out of
the cycle
and freedom from that doubt the cycle
and tell me if you've ever felt like
this because
this was my story for a really long time
there's this thing that i really want to
do
and i remember having conversations
meeting people and they'd be like what
do you do
and i'm like okay well i'm a social
media marketer but i really want to
launch courses i
really want to coach i really want to do
this thing and i just couldn't do it
because i had those
those big aspirations in my brain of
like i have to create a course i have to
create a membership
i had this idea of what everyone else
was doing that i was looking up to that
it had to look the exact same and that
my journey had to be the exact same as
everyone else
but it didn't work for me because i
couldn't i just couldn't make it happen
here's a picture of my family
we're gonna do a quick intro background
story we're not gonna you know have you
ever
attended those presentations where it's
like 45 minutes of the person just
talking about themselves and not
any not any real content we're not doing
that so
um this is my family these are my three
little kids my name is ali bjerk
and you know a lot of people comment on
my ads because i do run
ads if you have youtube videos and you
have comments you can probably relate to
this but
they like to make fun of my last name
and say like oh you must be a jerk well
i'm not i'm from minnesota i'm minnesota
nice is the quote we always say
what i did before this was helping
online business owners to
launch and scale businesses um and
that's what i do in my coaching now
that they're totally time leveraged so
we're talking about group programs
um having digital products programs that
all sell themselves so there's no
trading dollars for hours
so as a previous doer of all the things
i
maxed out at about 80 probably 70 80k a
year when i was a service provider that
was like
the most money i could make and as soon
as i turned the system on
it changed everything so graphic
designer turned social media marketer
facebook ads manager
pretty much a master of or a doer of
many things but a master of none if
you've ever felt like that when you're
you're good at a lot you know
multi-passionate and you can't quite
get the funnel vision blinders on to
focus on one thing that was totally me
and i had major fomo like i wanted that
confidence to do the things that i
dreamt about i wanted the book i wanted
the courses i wanted to do public
speaking
and i was the marketer with no marketing
and i just really wanted a funnel baby
of my very own so if you've ever felt
like that
um and you feel like you're doing a
thing but you you can't quite
get it churning as fast as you want or
there's like too much friction in your
life where it's just not happening
maybe you can relate to where i came
from so
if you're here and you have big dreams
about what that business can look like
for you
if you want to make impact because you
know values are super important behind
all of this and doing it for the right
reasons it's always going to be more
successful when it's not just about
doing it for the money so of course
scaling in a really aligned and ethical
way and then having an idea in your back
pocket that you just can't
quite launch or you haven't figured out
the right method to do it this is going
to be helpful for that today
so what we're going to talk about i have
five different shifts within this
training
i'm going to show you why you don't have
to have you know be good at sales you
don't have to get on sales calls you
don't have to be super visible if you go
look at my social media right now i'm
not
i don't post every day i have not you
know
a ton of followers but it's because of
these shifts that i made in my own brain
to um it's pronounced minnesota
yeah i know i said it wrong but
you don't have to have the pr agency and
have all of those beautiful as seen on
logos on your website those were
thoughts that i had for a long time that
kept me stuck of like
maybe when i have the forbes logo on my
website or business insider maybe when i
have that
clout behind my name maybe then i'll do
something that actually generates money
but it didn't it was the stuff that was
keeping me paralyzed so maybe busy work
is keeping you paralyzed too i mean
maybe you're you're editing for hours
and hours on end or you're
trying to craft the perfect long-form
social media post or you're writing a
blog
and then you're going and searching for
the perfect the perfect image the stock
image search i don't know if any of you
have ever gotten stuck
in that where you're like oh i have to
find the perfect photo
and then you're ready to post it and
you're like oh i need a call to action
what am i what am i going to do i should
be growing my list i have to grow my
email list
and it's just like this crazy cycle and
every single time
you like get to the end of the day and
you're like what did i even do today
like nothing that actually
made money in my business like it all
felt like theoretically it should make
money but we get stuck in that cycle all
the time
so the five shifts we're covering today
are why photo shoots and fancy websites
don't matter
the thing to stop using where most
digital product creators go wrong
the four specific yes triggers that
every product must have so getting into
actually designing the product and then
going through my exact no fluff system
so this is where i'll show you ad spend
and all of the details behind
how i actually hit those big revenue
numbers in my business
so photo shoots and fancy websites don't
matter i don't know if you've ever you
know if you're like in the coaching
industry or a personal brand or an
expert
i remember when i first started in this
industry
it was you know probably six or seven
years ago when i
i realized that like online coaching was
a thing and personal brands were a thing
and that's also when i was doing a lot
of um a lot of work for
clients i started running their launches
and i started just diving into this
world because i loved learning
and i became an expert in all those
things but i was i was only operating
from client to client like a client
would pay me i'd spend all the money i
had no business savings account
and then at one point being a service
provider i had this breaking point in
february of 2018 i was totally maxed out
i was exhausted
three little kids brand new baby um and
i had a client push through a chargeback
so i don't know if you've ever
experienced that where you like you do
all the work for a client and then for
whatever reason they go call their
credit card company and like say that
the work didn't happen and then they can
pull the money right out of your account
worst experience ever and i it was a
chargeback for six thousand dollars i
did not have six thousand dollars in my
bank account
so i was stuck like i was had my back
against the wall
i was laying in bed like helping my son
fall asleep and i had the notification
from stripe on my phone pop
up and i didn't get stripe notifications
in those days so it's like six thousand
dollars is coming out of your account in
the morning
so i was freaking out like crying like
going to my husband like i don't know
what i'm gonna do so finally like i have
that back against the wall moment of
i have to launch something like i have
to do something i don't know when i'm
having another
one-on-one client coming in um and i
told my husband i'm like i just want to
quit i just want to be done
and he said just for six more months
like put your blinders on finally do the
things that you've been telling yourself
you want to do and let's just see what
happens and if in six months
it doesn't work you can quit you can go
do go be a personal trainer or go be a
real estate agent or like whatever crazy
ideas i presented to him that night he
was like
knock it off put your blinders on and go
do the work so
with all the things that had just
happened i knew i was i was stuck and i
had to make revenue really quickly i
knew launches
inside and out i knew digital products
inside and out i had been sitting
on some digital products that i kind of
like sort of launched quietly and no one
bought so then i like hid them away and
didn't want to tell anyone about them
because i wasn't proud of it
so i knew all about the traditional
launch method and if you've ever
thought about launching a course or a
group program it looks a little like
this
so it's got the traffic it has an opt-in
page it's got a thank you page then you
send emails and then you have a free
lead magnet and then you file you know
most people file them and forget about
them
then you bring them to an offer page you
send more emails maybe people book a
sales call maybe they don't and it's
just a really long runway to not
even know if it's going to work or not
and i you know frankly at this point i
did not have time for that
so i didn't have followers i think i had
like 400 people on my email list and
they were mostly like
well-meaning friends from high school
and my parents and you know some family
members
so i couldn't launch anything to my list
um i knew i had to do it differently i
knew the traditional launch method would
not work
so i had to rely on a cold audience
because i didn't have anything else
i didn't have any time to waste so with
this new method it didn't matter
that i didn't have a brand i didn't have
any followers most people
didn't even make it to my website they
just went from ad to sales page so
website was relevant and the success was
based on
bringing them through a simple
three-step journey so
brand facebook group business page
profile social media source like none of
that actually mattered
for people seeing the offer and being
like yes this is awesome
i'm gonna buy it and then the money
coming into my account
so i did something that most of the you
know quote unquote gurus would consider
impossible and reckless i put it all on
the line with this tiny offer like all
of my
my expertise into one offer um and it
looked a little bit like this so i had
paid traffic
that went to a sales page um the sales
page had
then went to an order page the order
form if you've ever seen those order
bumps on it where it's like a check box
to add on to the order
that was what the order form looked like
and then from there it was a one-time
offer upsell page
you can also add on one-time offer
downstairs and then you bring them to
an order confirmation page so it's very
very quick step-by-step
through the offer they don't go anywhere
else there's not a bunch of crazy emails
that get shot off and you know
right away on page one that sales page
you know if it's working or not so
you're not relying
on trying to figure out you know are
people opening my emails what are my
email open rates
are people gonna show up to the sales
call it like takes away
so much of the unknowns that can come
with the traditional launch method
so this is what if you've if you've ever
built a funnel
in your business to sell something or to
get get someone on the phone or to make
a sale
if you're doing a free pdf let's say
just for easy math
if you're using ads and you get you know
for
five dollars you get a thousand people
to sign up look at these drop-off rates
and these are like industry
benchmark numbers so if you have a
thousand people sign up
20 or 200 people will actually open your
emails these are pretty standard rates
three percent of people typically will
click so of the 200 that people that
opened six people are clicking through
30
of people will register for that call
with you that's two people
and if you close and if people show up
for the call say one person buys if
you're not selling something that's at
least
five thousand dollars you're not even
going to break even on what you spent on
ads
and that's what most people are doing is
having that free pdf and just crossing
their fingers on the back end
that their funnel will convert
i love gifs so you'll see that through
this presentation but it's funny because
people as i started doing this strategy
and you know speaking publicly about
this strategy
people would comment on my ads again ad
commenters it's like a whole thing
they'd comment and be like there's no
way
you actually did this like you're full
of crap you're a liar this is not
possible i went and looked at your
instagram and you only have like 4 000
followers
and then i went and looked at your
facebook page and you only have eight so
this guy was like
going everywhere and doing all this math
and like based on how many followers you
have if x percent of those people buy
and you sold a product for 20. so he's
like had this whole thing figured out
i was like i don't know what to tell you
buddy like they saw my ad they went to
the sales page and they bought
there was no other looking around there
was no trust that needed to be
pre-established because it's based on
that
impulse purchase that what's in it for
me is so clear when they see the sales
page that they can make that buying
decision
immediately when i first came on to the
into the coaching world
someone actually like there's a whole
thread that was going around that was
like
if you want to build rapport and you
want to have a big social media
following and you want to
have people like trust you as their
coach you need to go to paris and put on
a ball gown and like
get your photo taken in front of the
eiffel tower like that's how you built
trust
according to when i first came into the
this online business world
it was all about vanity followers and
really quickly i realized like the
people who were
actually making real money in their
businesses didn't have that stuff
they just had funnels they just had
people coming in they had paid traffic
and they were making offers
so when you're spending all this time
creating an image and not
actually making money in your business
none of it really matters and if it's
helping you keep your doors open
and you know keep paying your team for
time all you know continuously
because you're focusing on the wrong
metrics you can't go to the bank and be
like hey i want to buy a house here my
million million uh followers they're
like we don't care we just want
money so focusing on that as the main
goal of your business
is was a really big shift for me too
so your current perceived social status
has nothing to do with the amount of
money that you're making
right now let me know if that if that
hits like if you resonate with that if
it makes sense
this is justine she was someone that i
worked with you can see when she turned
on her tiny offer funnel like if you
this is her stripe screenshot and i
absolutely love when my students
stripes screenshots like the most fun
thing ever so she was saying
she at the end of the month doubled the
previous revenue from
you know the previous month and i asked
her like
what are you doing now what's what are
you working less and she said yes i just
hired a va
and now i'm only you know logging in
one day a week so to watch her go double
from what she was doing before even
before having that 12 000
screenshot she was at like a couple
thousand a month
so it's really amazing to see how
quickly this can start working for
people
this is ellen yin she was another
student of mine she
i think has gone on to launch 700 000 or
make 700 000 from this strategy but this
was one of her first posts back in april
and she was like oh my gosh this is
amazing
i've made twenty seven hundred dollars
so far but i think it's really cool to
watch the progress that people make
because
the first time like i remember when i
made the first sale to a stranger and i
was like oh my gosh like this person
doesn't know me i've never been on the
phone with them
they just bought something and then it
just kept happening and i'd put a dollar
into ads and i make two or three dollars
back
and it felt like the best kind of
gambling available because you put money
in and you you get more money out than
what you spent
so seeing people's whole journey through
this is is really really fun
i celebrate the first ab sales as much
as the people that are like oh my gosh i
just crossed a million dollars because
all it takes is that one sale to like
show you that you can do it you know to
sell to a stranger for the first time
from an ad is like the most amazing
feeling ever
so shift number two is to stop giving it
all away for free i
i hinted about that on the last um you
know when i talked about pdfs but that's
what a lot of people are doing
so if we look at data from nielsen
research it's like a big research firm
that knows a lot about how we're doing
things
and they say that the average customer
journey is 21 days
it takes an average of 32 exposures to
your brand to actually make a buying
decision
and if you think about how you use media
like if you picture yourself on an
average
evening maybe hanging out with your
partner watching tv you probably have
your phone in your hand
might be bouncing around between you
know looking at youtube comments looking
at videos looking at podcasts maybe
checking your instagram dms looking at
facebook watching tick tocks like
we are all over the place and so are
your buyers so are the people that
you're trying to attract with your brand
so we're seeing 10 000 ads per day
simultaneously so
the the amount of sensory input that
we're getting on a daily basis
is insane and this is what is happening
with a new landscape of digital
marketing like this is a normal
this is what's happening like this this
is just what we're up against
so if we're going to shift into having
that abundance mindset through this
whole presentation
let's flip it to the positive instead of
being like womp womp 10
000 ads like i can't compete no one's
going to see my stuff whatever i'm not
going to try
if we shift into abundance it's a
greater opportunity
than ever before because another stat
people are spending almost 10 hours a
day on their phones
every single day so we're hooked to our
devices for the majority of the day
and if you know how to get in front of
the right people and be there with your
ads all the time
you don't have to be doing all the work
you don't have to be creating the social
media you don't have to be online
constantly
you know all over the place trying to
connect with people and trying to drive
those conversations you can just let it
happen naturally with your ads and get
in front of all the right people at the
right time so it's expensive either way
it's going to be expensive costing you a
lot of time or it's going to be
expensive costing you ads
or money paying for ads
so you can either live on social media
non-stop
which you know as we covered in the
intro i i really like to have that
balance life and not be online all that
often
so it was important to me to have
something that worked behind the scenes
so that i could wake up to sales so that
i knew
things were functioning and that the
foundation of my business was solid
without me needing to be online and
responsible for that
so if we think about what type of buyers
we want to attract when i said like
attracting the right people at the right
time
what does that actually mean so when you
think about who are the quote unquote
right people so if you're selling
if you want to sell other products if
you want to monetize your business
we want to make sure that we're
attracting people who want to
save their time and spend money so when
you can create things like
starter kits or blueprints or templates
um the very first product that i sold
was a social media calendar it was
called livestream365.
so it attracted people that were like
yes give me all the social media ideas i
want to save my time
i don't want to sit and have to think of
this myself just give me the product
so when you think of that when you're
creating your digital products instead
of people who
want to spend time to save money you
know you're attracting a different type
of buyer a buyer who's going to be with
you for the long haul they're going to
be loyal they want to keep
saving their time they value their time
so much that they're like yeah what
other products you have what else can i
buy
how else can i invest in myself so that
i can shortcut my learning curve and
keep moving even faster
so people don't need to trust you to
spend twenty seven dollars on a product
so if you're asking like what is a tiny
offer
typically it's anything that's fifty
dollars or less it doesn't have to be
twenty seven dollars
twenty seven dollars is a fun number i
was born on the 27th so i'm a little
biased
but it can be anything less than 50 it
has that impulse purchase
price point i mean it's basically like
if you were to take a friend out for
lunch
what would that price be i mean or
coffees or starbucks whatever
as long as your product is at that right
price point where
it can be the impulse purchase and it
shows that it's going to save them time
it's going to educate them and it's
going to inspire them to think even
bigger
those are the products that i've really
seen take off
so also when you run ads and when you
have digital products available
that people can sample what it's like to
work with you or sample what it is that
you offer
you you're essentially creating a
different uh
a different perception of your brand so
i have two different examples here
in my brain this is like the freebie
versus starting with the paid product
these are two different bags that i
found on well not
found both on amazon found one on amazon
found the left one on amazon
the right one is louis vuitton if you
look at the two bags just
you know what they look like they're
very similar they're both black they
both have tassel thingies they both have
little circle grommets on there they're
really not that different
but one is two thousand dollars and one
is fourteen dollars
fourteen thirty nine and it's probably
on sale so when you think about that
like
how do i create my how do i give my
brand that feeling of being the louis
vuitton brand how do i elevate
my status and my perception and my you
know my brand clout
you have to show up consistently there's
something that happens to people's
brains when they see people in their
news feeds all the time
it just shifts the way they think about
you and all of a sudden you're like a
celebrity to them you're famous
in their eyes because you're running ads
because you have a system
because you've put in the effort to run
ads pay for your ads with your front you
know top of the funnel
digital product and then have people on
your email list ready to buy other
things from your business
so this is katherine she worked with a
lot of different coaches
she was trying to sell a mastermind she
was like a higher ticket coach
and she was telling me like i can't sell
my mastermind like i'm you know i know
i'm really good at what i do i know i'm
an expert
but it's so hard for me to get people to
commit to saying yes to this
so she ended up launching a tiny offer
to her list and she made fifteen
thousand dollars just from her existing
list in community
so she was really happy with that and
this was the testimonial she gave me
at that point but then it gets better
she sent me this message
just you know probably a couple months
later and she's like oh hey by the way i
made another 110 000
since the last time i messaged you and i
was like
okay that's awesome but then if you look
she's from germany so she's got
the euro on here but if you look at the
level of investments that people were
suddenly making with her business
they were you know 11 000 year old 10
000 year old
8 000 euro like it totally shifted the
way people saw her brand
and they were willing to see her as the
expert they were willing to invest even
more
because they started with this initial
fifteen thousand dollars she was able to
segment
her list from buyers um you know
non-buyers to buyers and then keep
marketing the people that had already
purchased from her
there's a quote in the sales world
that's like people who pay pay attention
no matter what it is
if you can if you can get people
interested
then they're more likely to continue
buying brandon says
the opposite of jab jab right hook yeah
totally but it's different right because
jab jab right hook is like free free
free i still do content i still have
like my my jab jab right hook gary
vaynerchuk style
is my content it's what i put on social
media it's my stories it's like my
typical
journey through the you know whatever my
reality tv show is
it's hard to compare a digital product
business to gary vaynerchuk because what
is he actually
monetizing like he's in a position where
he's an expert he's
investing he's keynote speaking most of
us can't start there
most of us can't start with just free
all the time because our businesses will
dry up and die
so it's it like i love that comparison
and i think it's so
interesting to think about it because
we're learning from give free stuff all
the time from people who aren't in the
same position that we're in
so just some i mean it's like a whole
tangent i can go on obviously because
i'm biased but
it's interesting to think about so this
is christy christie
has a business that is called girl
hustle it's a fitness business
you can see in her striped screenshot
when she launched her tiny offer
all of a sudden she's making tons and
tons of sales
and she has a fitness brand so she had a
well-established following
she has you know she had lots of
instagram followers she has a membership
so she was able to get people i think
she was making like a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars
since she sent me this screenshot and
she was able to get people in with a
tiny offer and then
the next thing that she offered to them
was her existing membership so she got
more sales on the front end
and also had more leads to bring into
her membership that was already existing
so that's another cool way to think
about
doing it so shift number three is where
most digital product creators go wrong
more gifts obviously so there's a big
issue when people talk about
quote-unquote passive income a lot of
people go into
thinking they're going to build a course
thinking they're going to have digital
products and then it's just
like creating it and then like okay cool
i'm done
i made my products let me go retire in
fiji like i'm ready to roll
however that's not the reality and like
i'm here to tell you that as someone who
has passive income products it's not
it's not just set it and forget it
there's customer service
there's managing the ads there's
improving the products like there's so
much that comes along
with passive income that the work shifts
like you create it and you can sell it
all the time but there is maintenance
like you can't just go to the gym
and eat all the healthy foods and get to
your ideal weight and be like hey cool
like i'm never gonna step foot on a
treadmill again or eat another salad
because i've made it like i'm good
that's not what happens with digital
products either
so where most people go wrong is that
they think
they are the expert right like everyone
here is probably has an expertise
they're probably a thought leader has
you have a business something you're
passionate about um
and we think we know our buyers better
than they know themselves so like we'll
create what what we know they need is
expert like okay
go buy this product because it's gonna
change your life but the person that
you're advertising to is like
i don't really want that like i don't
that's not what i think i need i'm in a
totally different place
so the big shift here is to create what
people think they need and again another
fitness example because i
i love it's just like so relative to
business but
say you're a fitness provider you're
like a fitness coach
and you know if someone's going to have
lasting lifetime results that they need
to sleep well they need to drink water
they need to do cardio they need to
weight lift they need to
you know balance their macros and like
all these different things but the
person
if you would run someone you know run an
ad to someone where it's like this is
the whole package you get everything you
ever need to maintain
your healthiest weight for the rest of
your life they're like whoa
like that's a lot of work that sounds
like it's gonna take forever and i just
want the 21 day quick fix like i just
want a meal plan i want a juice cleanse
like i want the thing
that's going to help me look great at my
high school reunion in two weeks like
just give me that
so when you're an expert and you are an
ethical expert there's like a
there's like a disconnect between that
because we feel unethical like well i
don't want to sell them the quick fix
because that's not what they need that's
not going to actually help
them long term but there's a little bit
of a
like a middle ground that you can meet
them at where you if you create
something that you know is going to
get their attention and get them into
your world and then within that product
you start shifting their beliefs about
here's your juice cleanse and if you
feel great after this
why don't you consider being plant-based
or why don't you you know start drinking
more water you can start
when like when you attend a webinar or a
training a lot of it is belief shifting
i mean
essentially what we're doing even here
on this training is like thinking about
things differently so if you can get
someone
into your tiny offer and like change the
way they see something or change their
perception and shift their belief
then your other products make more sense
and if you are someone who sells higher
ticket coaching or other programs
then you know you have the right person
because they're you know their belief
has
it's grown or like their self belief and
what they can even accomplish if you can
build all of that into your tiny offer
and even have mentions of it where you
know at the end of every module it's
like hey if you want
if you want more help with this you can
book a call with our team or if you want
to do this
you know here's a sales page or a
webinar you can watch so you make it
almost like a
sales tool for your other products
that's one way to do it
otherwise if you want to scale more
horizontally where if you want to have a
lot of different types of tiny offers
like if that's more realistic for your
market
you can totally do that too that's why
this is like a one-size-fits-all
strategy
so when you know your audience well
enough
sometimes as experts we create that
competency gap where we're like i'm
going to create this product over here
and your audience is like no actually
like i wanted that thing over there like
this is the thing that i'm that's
keeping me up at night for example when
i launched live stream 365 as my first
offer
it was all about going live every single
day when i first tried to launch it
it took me three tries to get it right
so the first time i tried to launch this
product
it was uh it was live it was live stream
systems for sales coaches
and nobody bought it like no one wanted
it at all
because it was about sales funnels
people were like i don't want to funnel
like if i could just
be visible like if i could just be
confident and get my face on camera then
people would want to
want to sign up but they'd want to work
with me so when i really listened and i
really
dug into what the market was actually
asking for that product
it had a lot of the same content inside
of it but it shifted into being
a calendar of ideas where all you have
to do is go live for three and a half
minutes a day
and you're gonna get clients oh and when
you get clients here's a sales funnel
that you can use from your live streams
to turn them
into you know funneled clients basically
so same product but the angle was
completely different and it made a huge
difference
for people actually buying it like then
it finally started selling
so what most people do here's another
part of the shift a lot of people when
they create a digital product like this
they think of it in terms of one product
like okay i'm going to create an ebook
i'm going to create a mini course and
i'm going to sell it
and that's going to be it but when you
can use psychological buying triggers
and you create a whole product suite for
people it starts overcoming their
objections
and you can make a lot more money from
one entry point than you would if you
leave off like the order bump in the
upsell
so this is a super nerdy picture of me
at target i love target
um and it's an example of what a product
suite is so when you think about
creating a whole product suite for
people we see these on end caps
at stores like target or marshalls or
whatever we look at it you say you're in
the bathroom aisle and it's like got the
towels and the drying rack and the soap
holder and the
all the things same with this like super
sugary
sundae end cap if i wanted to make an
ice cream sundae
there's everything i'd ever need right
here on this end cap it's got the cones
it's got the hershey syrup it's got you
know marshmallows it's even giving me
ideas of things that i might add
it has everything but the ice cream so
when you start thinking about that
like your digital products and you know
your audience well enough to know
what buying you know what pain points
they think they're solving
there's always a solving and agitating
cycle when it comes to buying so when
you solve one pain point
there becomes a new level there's a new
you know there's a new pain point that
they want to solve so when you can
predict that
for people when you know them well
enough to create this whole buying suite
that's when products really get
profitable so for example my live stream
365
started with that calendar the second
screen grab you'll see here is my
was the order bump um which you can't
really see on the screenshot but
with when you put in it's a two-step
order form so the first step is putting
in your name and email that's another
hack to grow your email list and then
the second step of the order form is
where the order bump appears
so the second order bump of my overall
offer suite was a social media
repurposing training the idea being
it's going to help them get results even
faster from
their first purchase so that's what the
order bump should do help them get
results even faster
so the social media repurposing training
is like hey you just bought this live
stream 365 product
if you want to go even further faster
you got to repurpose those videos you
can turn them into quote cards on
instagram you can
grab the videos and put them on youtube
like you can do all these different
things
so those two went together the third
step was a sales training essentially
it was a sales funnel training so if
you're visible all the time
you're going to need you're you're gonna
need a funnel the product was called
client multiplier method
which naming you know naming is a huge
piece of creating products that feel new
that feel exciting for people
so having the methods the systems you
know all of those things like our brains
love novelty we love when things feel
like new opportunities
so having the sales training as the
client multiplier method that's what
they get next so once you're visible all
the time
you're repurposing once you are you know
you've got that on lockdown
you're gonna have so many clients coming
in that you have to automate your sales
you have to help people get to
that next step because you're going to
be so busy that you're not going to have
time to reach
every single one of the people who want
to reach you individually so you need a
system
so i want to illustrate the difference
with i created a shopify site around the
same time
so with shopify similar products no
traffic being run to it just set it and
forget it put it on my website
back you know a nice little tab at the
top of my website that said shop
and this is what i made in that same
time period about probably about
500 a month which for passive income
products set it and forget it that
wasn't horrible i mean if that if i
didn't have such
aspirational goals and if i didn't know
what ads could produce i'd be like sweet
500 that i didn't have to work for
however
exact same products with ads running to
them in that sequence
generated 285 000 without changing
much other than having the flow that we
talked about having the steps where
people can upgrade their orders
and add even more on that's gonna just
serve them even more like i think that's
a big distinction that i made in my own
brain of like
people are gonna be ticked like i keep
selling them stuff they're gonna be
annoyed
but when you come at it from like a
service standpoint of like what else can
i give them what
will help them get to that end results
even faster that makes
a huge difference i mean even
energetically in the product and like
how you're writing your copy
people care about that stuff and they
care that you care about them so
that's like a total different subject i
could talk about but anyway so you can
see
from this slide how many how much of
that i think
on here i break it down so from this
with the order bump and the upsell i
would have left 156 000
on the table had i not did i say that
right 156 000 yes
left on the table if i didn't have the
order bump or the one time offer like
just from the the live stream alone
that's still like 180 thousand dollars
that's still pretty good
but once you see how much i spent on ads
then it's not as exciting because it's
like that would have been a break even
strategy
so when you have the the order bump and
the upsell that's really where the
profit comes in especially with all the
updates we're seeing and volatility
happening with ios 14
with the ads updates i don't know if you
guys have been all up on that
but but it is important to have
something that breaks even on on the
front and then has
a separate piece of the order or the
order bump in the upsell that is really
responsible for the profit so the
difference
why this worked it was an offer not a
product suite that's why when people are
like what's the difference between tiny
offers and trip wires
totally different strategy tripwires
oftentimes are just
unrelated like a quick buck a way to add
something on the back end to get people
to buy where this
this is a whole like if you've ever read
there's a book called
pre-suasion by robert cellini that's a
really good book
and it's about getting people's minds
right and like priming them
to continue being buyers this sets
people up for success because
it's an immersive product and when you
design it right and you have videos and
you have downloads and you have you know
trello boards or audios or whatever else
it's like a fully immersive product
experience so
they're not going to forget your name
when you download a pdf and you like
file it
you're like i think i downloaded a a
freebie with
some topic from some person like it's
not as memorable because
they don't have all their different
senses being hit with listening to you
and seeing you and reading something
that you've created
so the product suite really makes that
possible other differences from
most you know tripwire maybe not
tripwires but set it and forget it
digital products are
that this uses the direct response
copywriting strategies
so if you've ever seen those long form
sales pages and you're like
oh my gosh who reads all of this a lot
of people don't read them
but the point is like as you look
through a long form sales page you're
you're you're looking for the highlight
reel you're looking at the photos you're
looking at the headings
the underlined words i mean even that is
enough to create an emotional connection
with the buyer
because of the way that most of these
long-form sales pages are created and
if you've seen a few of them they're you
know they're all very similar where they
they build rapport at the top like they
have
actually at the top they have like a
hook that gets your attention
and then builds a connection with you
like have you ever felt like this
here's why it gets even worse but it
doesn't have to look like that this is
what it could look
look like introducing the name of my
amazing product so
every single page builds that empathy it
builds a connection
like when you can do that with your
products that makes a huge difference
too
the other difference is paid media for a
limitless
flow of leads towards the offer
so when amazon added this buy now button
which you know is like literally a swipe
of your thumb on your phone
which don't let your children realize
that's possible because mine did
and there were a lot of orders that had
to be canceled when amazon added this
button
though essentially in our internet
marketing digital product world it's the
equivalent of the one-click upsell
just adding that button increased their
sales by 30
and that's amazon like they're already a
bajillion dollar company 30
is insane because it makes it easy for
people we are so
wired for immediate gratification we
like speed we like being able to get
things quickly
you can't make people click around too
much to get your products or re-enter
their payment information or like have
to visit a different page
we want it we want it quick and we want
it easy so when you can build systems
like this
that help people do that it makes a huge
difference also mock-ups
are another thing that help people
visualize digital products
when you can make the you know like an
intangible digital
file that people would open on their
computer when it feels more tangible and
they can start visualizing
themselves logging into what the client
portal looks like or you know
with the ebooks if there are trainings
that look like it's a physical book
it makes a huge difference for their
their mindset of what
what it looks like to buy your product
and when you can create that
visualization for them
it helps them make that final buying
decision of like yes
i want this and i'm going to go for it
i'm going to get my credit card or i'm
going to log on to paypal and i'm going
to spend 27
on this so i every single summer i'm
actually leaving for my third annual
rv trip with my family we went to banff
national park
the first year because it was canada was
open you can get into canada
we couldn't last year we can't this year
so we're not doing that but
the first year that i had this system up
and running running i got to go
watch the sunrise over lake louise which
was like a total bucket list item for me
in my business like i left my phone in
the rv just because i want to be super
present when i got back
from my little walk my kids were still
sleeping i think my husband was even
still sleeping in the rv
when i got back to my family my phone
was there with all of these payment
notifications so
what would what would it look like for
you if
you stopped working for two weeks if you
stepped out from your business and
you're like
i'm going on vacation i'm out would you
still make money
on the back end
this is lindsay she was a service
provider she's a digital marketer
agency or digital marketing agency owner
she had some family
um like her little girl got sick and she
had to be out and it coincidentally was
right after she had launched her own
tiny offer funnel so she says i made
three
three thousand five hundred dollars from
my um
offer itself and because of who i
brought in with the tiny offer
i sold two of my powerhouse programs so
that equaled fifteen thousand dollars
of upsells like higher ticket upsells so
while she was gone while she was out
she made nineteen thousand dollars in
sales she said this is huge for my
business and my life and i'm so grateful
for ali in this program it's opening up
um yeah like a thousand times over you
need to build one of these systems
in your business this is tasha of lady
boss studio she sells
canva templates different logos she's a
very creative amazing designer
and this is what it looked like for her
when she launched her tiny offer she has
since
crossed a million dollars in revenue so
these are
old screenshots but she sent me a boxer
message and i have the audio on my
instagram somewhere where she's like i
just crossed a million dollars
so it's crazy how fast this can work i
mean she she was debating between
working with me on building a tiny offer
and joining another program her initial
goal from joining this other like agency
designer program was to
add another forty thousand dollars of
revenue for the whole year in her
business and
now she does that in just a couple weeks
because of this system
so on to shift number four what are the
four specific yes triggers that every
product must have like how do we
i'm a huge buyer psychology person like
i love studying our brains and what
releases dopamine and gets us excited
about things so the four specific yes
triggers
that's where we're going to get into
like this hi i can't talk psychology
behind this so the way to get buyers for
life to get people who want to continue
being
in your circle keep you know just being
near you because they love you so much
you can't sell a pdf for 27 and i
like i always lurk in comments on other
people's
in other people's groups because i think
it's really interesting to just see what
people are saying and what they're
really thinking and people will reveal
a lot about themselves in other people's
groups and
there was this whole thread about 27
offers and tiny offers
um which is a registered trademark by
the way so i should have said something
but i didn't
anyway so they they're talking about
these offers and they're like
if i buy one more 27 pdf i
i'm gonna be so mad in these businesses
like i would never work with this person
so i'm sitting there like reading this
i'm like yeah exactly like you can't
just
put a 27 price tag on an existing pdf as
we talked about
that's not what it's about at all right
it's about that immersive experience
it's about really connecting with your
buyers so that there's a loyalty that's
being built there's you know
reciprocity like they love what how much
value they got for 27
so we don't want to sell crappy 27
products because
people will never trust you they will
never come back they will be angry and
they'll probably ask for a refund
which is not as fun as you know having
passive income coming in you don't want
to have
passive refunds going out so you're
under strict orders as part of
part of this training now that you've
gotten to see the whole system
no pricing pdfs at 27 that's not what
this is all about
what it needs to be about instead is
creating a product that saves them time
i mean that's the biggest thing
psychologically that we talked about who
you're attracting if you're attracting
the person who wants to invest in
themselves that makes a huge difference
so it needs to show that it's going to
save them time
it also needs to give them control so if
it is a template
we all believe that we're special and
unique so even if it's a template it
needs to be customizable so that it
gives them control
and make it clear on your sales page
like you can make this your own it's
super easy to customize
here's how you do it it also needs to
teach them something new
and inspire them to think even bigger so
if you can inspire them
towards whatever that next vision of
themselves whatever that you know next
version of themselves is
you can help them start seeing that then
other products that you have will make
sense and they'll they'll be forever
grateful that you were the person that
inspired them to
to know that there was something even
bigger and better for their lives
so a captivating product suite if you
think about if you're starting you're
listening and like your mind is
already stewing like jordan says if if
you're in that point you're like okay
cool like how do i do this
start thinking about what your buyer
journey looks like or what a customer
journey looks like
for someone that you'd work with so if
they're coming into your world
what are people saying to you when
they're first being introduced or
say they're getting on a call with you
and they're like i just really
want to be here but i'm stuck here so if
you can think about where they're
starting
you know what's point a and what's point
b and what are all those steps in
between
so with the live stream calendar it was
like okay people need to just
start showing up on on video if they can
just hit record
they'll realize it's not as scary if
they can just commit to three and a half
minutes
and some people didn't realize the
underlying inspiration behind the
product because i knew
if i could get people comfortable if i
could get them visible
that a whole world would open up for
them right so like
excuse me of course i get a frog in my
throat this is like upper limiting every
time i do a presentation
every time so i knew that if people got
their faces on camera
if they could commit to this goal and
they're proving to themselves that
they can do what they say they're going
to do they can be visible that it's not
going to kill them to have their face on
camera like
it's actually going to be really amazing
that they can build confidence i knew
that that person
would be like oh my gosh this changed my
life even though it's a social media
calendar like it's not
anything groundbreaking but because i
had all of these core elements and i
knew
that whole buyer journey of what they
needed to believe and think in order to
be more qualified
for other things and be like ready for
other things i was able to
choreograph that in a specific order
where i met them where they were at with
what they thought they needed
brought in that order bump that would
help them get results faster and then
finally
the upsell was the thing ultimately that
i knew that i could help them with to
get more clients in the door
so when you think about the result or
transformation that you help a client
achieve
i'm sure there's a result where whatever
you're offering or what you're creating
they're different after having met you
they're different they're a different
person
their life is different after having
been near you so what is that
transformation
what are you helping people do think
about that and then just brain dump like
get a blank piece of paper and
and put down everything someone would
need to think this is where you can
start creating like frameworks or
different systems behind what you do if
you if you sell like happiness which i
say quote unquote
um that's what you know if it's
something that is intangible like
people are happier after they've gone
through your program or they have better
relationships or they have more
self-confidence
when you can name it as a framework
suddenly it feels tangible so it's like
the happiness method or
you know like even the love languages
that feels like a framework that was
suddenly a viable thing even though it's
like here's how you better communicate
with your spouse
that doesn't feel as tangible right so
when you can translate whatever your
specialty is into a framework or a
method blueprint
strategy all those hype words that end
up at the end of products
it helps people feel it it helps people
connect with that product so once you've
done that and you've brainstep
or brain dumped all of the steps that's
the beginning of designing your perfect
tiny offer
when it comes to directors direct i need
to slow down
direct response sales copywriting there
are these different pages that you would
think about when it comes to
writing your offer if there's any skill
set that you can develop
as a marketer of your own business it's
direct response sales copywriting so
direct response just means you can write
in a way that elicits an emotional
response
from the reader when you're creating
this type of offer there are
essentially six different things that
you need to be able to write so the main
offer sales page
the one-time offers sales page because
these are those longer form sales page
that i talked about
then your order form page the
confirmation page which is really easy
the confirmation page is like hey thanks
for ordering here's what you can expect
next
and then the main offer video sales
letter so off also called a vsl
you can pretty much read your sales page
or your first sales page and that's what
ends up
feeling like it's a video sales letter
you know we don't want to get too
scripted there and
you guys understand video if you're here
but when people
have the video sales letter and they're
like you made a great choice
because you bought product x like it
feels stilted
they're not going to really resonate
with what it is you're selling
especially you know that was like an
example of what people say for the oto
video sales letters
so just be natural just be just be
excited about what your product
is and like what that transformation is
when i look at my
client results and i see how much it's
changed their lives like why would i not
want to talk about this and be excited
in a video sales letter like this is
going to be amazing for people
this is tamiko she went through the
program she helps parents
get their kids napping which if you have
kids you know that's like a really
amazing thing it's a huge pain point for
people
and she launched she had never really
monetized a digital product she was
doing one-on-one coaching with
her clients she was i mean even going
into their homes and like
helping the kids sleep in person so for
her to be able to pull herself out
especially during corona
when you know going into people's homes
for a while wasn't really recommended
and she was able to turn it into
a digital product at naptimefix.com
she made i think she ended up making 5k
in the first 30 days she made 11 sales
in her first week just by
promoting it to her existing followers
or to people she'd work with finally
they had a framework they had a way that
they could get to mikko in their lives
without her physically
needing to be in their homes like okay
now you know
now don't go in if baby's crying or not
like go hug baby
like she she was able to coach people
through her system
her nap time system without needing to
physically be there so that's another
way to think about it too of like
what do you do when you're in person
with someone like what do you say to
them
what do you coach them through what
questions are you asking are there
different
segments that people typically go
through or different phases that you see
clients often follow through
you can put that into a digital product
too because it like removes your time
from the equation so these are these are
low-cost
low-touch products you don't want to be
needed
to help them get to the results so it's
like how do you pull your time out of it
and any any any touch from you or any
words from you
any coaching from you how do you pull
that that physical presence needed most
of the time when we're working with
people
how do we get them the result without
you needing to be there
these are other clients that said after
changing direction and making a whole
new offer i made my first sale
that's encouraging because it doesn't
always work the first time i'm reading
this book called i know i'm always with
the book recommendations
but a book called grit by angela
duckworth and she talks about
just what is grit especially when it
comes to entrepreneurialism
the idea of like consistently showing up
and even when it's hard work
just doing the work non-stop and being
willing to pivot and not give up on a
dream and just keep running towards
whatever that goal is
sometimes it takes shifting your offer
sometimes it takes
rewriting the sales page or changing the
first topic or having an aha moment
and not being afraid to pivot it's the
client the clients that i've worked with
who are like
i don't want to rewrite my sales page i
just wrote this sales page it's fine
even if it's not working like i'm not
going to do any more work
it's a lot harder to get results when
you're not testing things russell
brunson himself who's like
the creator of clickfunnels you know he
should know a lot about
funnels he said that only one out of
three of every single funnel that he
launches
actually works out of the gate like
right away starts functioning the other
ones take testing they take tweaking
so having that idea of knowing that
you're just launching to to get data to
get ideas you know get feedback from
people and if it is what they actually
want
that can make a huge difference in the
the actual success of your products
so the exact system just to break down
all the numbers of what it actually
looked like
but first i have a random fact that i
learned on children's podcast
and that is that cheerios spends one
third of the cost of every single box on
advertising so if you go to the grocery
store right now
you can probably buy a box of cheerios
for three ish dollars maybe it's more
with inflation i don't know we'll say
three for easy math so one dollar
of every you know 30 of their entire
budget or 33
is going to advertising and they've been
around
i think when i googled it it was like
1928 or something like that is when
cereal started coming on the market so
they've been around for a really long
time
and they're still advertising but a lot
of us business owners were like
um you know i don't i'm not to do ads
like i don't think i'm ready
i don't think it's a it's a good way to
spend money like we're not seeing it as
an investment
so i want to challenge you on that like
what's your gut check moment when you
hear that
me before ads i would have been like
whatever cheerios like you and your
million dollar company
cool that's awesome good for you but i
can't do that because i can't even write
myself a paycheck like be serious
this is not a realistic thing for me a
small business owner
so setting that limiting belief aside
and realizing once you have the
foundation and you have digital products
and you have this system
all it is is messaging all it is is
finding the audiences
it's just a process that you can perfect
that you can learn it's not
some crazy out of reach thing like maybe
buying a billboard
in a metro area like we don't have to do
that for advertising anymore we don't
have to buy a super bowl spot
commercial we can compete right next to
nike next to
costco next to all the big brands even
as small business owners you can you can
start an ad campaign and spend 30
dollars a day
and have your ads appear right next to
people who are you know
they used to be the only ones who could
advertise so stop relying on the wrong
metrics we talked about that all the way
back
in shift number one when you rely on
not followers and not engagement and not
likes and not shares when you rely on is
this generating
income in my business am i selling
something then you know
if it's working or not and because with
this system you know right away
you can turn things off if they're not
working it's not like that long launch
runway where it's two weeks of trying
ads and then being like crap
that didn't work you can spend thirty
dollars a day
get some validation scale your ad spend
which i'll show you how i did that in a
second
but it's super interesting so even at
the point of
this slide being created i had sold 12
000 copies of my tiny offer now that's
up to 25 000
copies of my tiny offer or various tiny
offers uh
even that you know if i look at people
who are interested in digital marketing
this is straight from facebook so if i
look
for people who are interested in and run
ads to people who are interested in
face or digital marketing i've only
sold to like half of a half of a percent
i don't even know if that's the right
math someone who's better at percentages
tell me but it's like a very small
amount
and i'm just getting started like even
with those numbers
i've barely even scratched the surface
of who's available to potentially be
interested in
what it is that i have to sell and if
you're listening and you're like
whatever
digital marketing is a business
opportunity like my market could never
work for this i've worked with parenting
coaches
i've worked with spiritual providers
i've worked with you know
decluttering specialists coaches of
parents like
this can work in every single industry
you might not have a pool of 27 million
people to start off with but
this can work in all sorts of different
industries
so when i started running ads i scaled
them very quickly
because i had a background in
advertising i could do this without
freaking out
however because my account was negative
by this point
and my credit cards maxed out at this
point i didn't have
a lot of room to run ads so i started
this is just like an illustration of
what it looked like so i started with 30
a day by day two i had well let's say
for easy math i started with a hundred
dollars that i could spend over three
days
so if i spent thirty three dollars a day
by day four
i already have money coming back into my
account from the sales that i made on
day one
so by day four i can essentially triple
what my ad spend was
wit and just keep scaling that or keep
water falling the amount that i was
spending on ads
so even by day 10 i could make 27 times
more sales than i could on day one
because of how much i could spend i
could increase my
my um ads budget so as long as you're
getting a return on ad spend or a ros
on what you're spending you can keep
scaling it so when
my strategy was like i have to make six
thousand dollars as fast as possible
i just kept scaling it and i kept
doubling it and i kept testing new
audiences and finding different pockets
i could test
so i ended up making it you know it
could be people that liked digital
marketing who were on iphones from
ages 24 to 29 was like an ad set and
then i would just create all of these
little micro ad sets
and that's how i was able to scale when
you
have a webinar launch strategy this is
what it looks like so if you have that
same budget
when i run a live webinar i'll spend i
usually start ads about
a week before the webinar so i would
have seven days
to spread out that same that same budget
you know if i only have 300
for my ads i'd have to try to make that
work for seven
days and then i wouldn't get any money
back until i knew the pitch worked i
knew people were booking calls maybe
people were buying
maybe i sell right on the webinar and
then i get the deposit on day 10. so as
you can see like as
far as sales strategies and lead growth
and being able to scale really really
quickly
it's a lot easier to scale from day one
to day 10
27 times if you want than it is with a
webinar strategy
so what most people are doing um
blogging podcasts
tick tock live streams igtv all of the
things but the one thing they're like
not facebook ads like i will not run
facebook ads i refuse
because they aren't seeing it as an
investment yet right like when you can
think of it as not gambling
when you it's a predictable return and
you can see
okay one dollar turns into two dollars
i'm gonna put money into that you know
that
whatever roulette system all day it's
like putting money into the atm and
getting
2x back when it's working it does take
time to get it working like we talked
about this isn't like a
you know create anything and run it out
to it and you're going to be an internet
millionaire
it takes messaging it takes knowing your
audience it takes clarity it takes
knowing what you actually want to create
but when you can test it and when you
can shift and pivot the offer and know
30 in if it worked or not it's so much
easier than when you have like this
massive ad spend
and when i when i'm running a webinar
and when i'm
advertising you know a higher ticket
program i'll spend
seventy thousand dollars to eighty
thousand dollars in a week
to get people on that webinar because
again i know the return on that it's
still gonna be profitable
but i couldn't start there like i didn't
even have that much credit available
anywhere
so when you can start smaller it's a lot
easier to build
build your way into that
so when i started my email list like i
said 445 people probably my mom and her
friends
facebook fan page had 700 instagram 4
400 because that's where i put all my
effort was on instagram
now my email list is 53 000 facebook fan
page i think it's closer to 10.
instagram i think i'm up to 12 maybe i
have to go look it might be higher than
that actually i can't remember
um but income since launch was 2.2
million dollars
and ad spend was about a million dollars
i know
right had you told me at the beginning
of this
like in the next year you're gonna spend
a million dollars on facebook ads
i'd be like nope not me not gonna happen
i don't know what you're talking about
because that was monopoly money to me
like that didn't happen that wasn't real
people who could do that started rich
like people who could do that
already had millions of followers that
wasn't real for a mom of minnesota
however here i am two years later
telling you that it's possible
so income after ads was 1.1 million
dollars
use that to scale a team because you
know as i said i like to be hands off i
like to be behind the scenes
and now my life is completely different
than it was prior to having this system
this was my little family um i found out
that i had crossed the million dollar
mark while i was at funnel hacking live
which was like the craziest story ever
my stripe account and paypal accounts
literally like
clicked over to the million dollar mark
while at funnel hacking live so i was
able to say
uh two people at funnel hacking live
like hey this happened while i was here
is there any way that i could walk
across the stage and like collect my two
comma club which you can see
right over there that way um and
i called my husband and i was i was in
nashville they were in minnesota
yes i have to say it like that for you
guys and he was like i'm coming i'm
gonna pack the kids up in the minivan
and we're driving to nashville so this
is my family
they got to be on stage with me and walk
even though you know like
people at the event were like no it's
only the person who won the award and i
was like
well i built this for them like i built
this with them
they have to be on stage with me so i
had like i was very stubborn
and i made it happen but now i have this
cute gift that i can use and my family
got to be on stage for that
so with having this system you're you're
never going to have to worry about
paying for ads because it's they're
going to pay for
themselves essentially like running ads
for free was my most controversial
headline on my ads but also you know got
the most engagement and the most
registrations
because people were like that's not true
you can never run an ad for free there's
no such thing as a free lunch
it's like okay but like also watch the
webinar because it's really good
working yourself to death is never going
to be a problem it's all just going to
start
functioning as it should as a business
owner having money coming in
consistently
so if you feel like jlo here with
facebook ads and you're like
it's just gonna be a loss it's it's not
meant for me it's never gonna work for
me
just think about it differently and like
give yourself a chance to experiment
with them and get them working
because it's amazing what it can do for
your email your email size you know your
the amount of followers you have it like
checks off all the boxes for
business growth when you have something
you can run consistently
i had my same tiny offer that live
stream 365 product i had that running
for
i think two years profitably by year two
it finally started to fizzle out a
little bit but
but there's a lot of calendars um so i
wasn't surprised people also aren't
really doing live streams the same way
now there's reels there's tick tock
there's youtube like when i launched
that
it was a lot different marketplace so
two years though is how long that that
product actually lasted
um so this is the blueprint once again
if we've been talking
or if you've been listening and you're
like what did she say it was again
it was paid traffic to a sales page with
the order form
if people don't buy you can send them
emails that's like an abandoned
cart sequence if you've ever been on a
clothing shop and you put something in
your cart and you don't end up buying
and then you get emails and you're like
wait come back
you can do that with your digital
products too then you can have an oto
or one-time offer upsell page if you
want to get crazy you can have a down
cell page you can have flash sales like
you can get as complicated
and different directions with this type
of blueprint as you want but for
simplicity's sake i just did these first
basically the first two steps so sales
page order form and upsell page and then
the confirmation page
and then brought them into my learning
management system
and went from there right here where
that big circle is that's where i knew
if it was working or not i've since
launched i think like three more tiny
offers and i've had to shut some of them
off and rework them
because they i missed the mark i didn't
quite have the messaging right
didn't feel like a new opportunity you
know didn't didn't quite have the right
hook
on the sales page so i knew within a day
or two that i needed to pivot
the product or the sales page and then
in doing so i was able to bring it back
and get it successful
with most traditional launch methods
like we talked about it's not until the
sales call when you know if it's working
or not so that's a really long
a long launch runway to know if you're
spending money
well or not so when it comes to this
type of funnel
i've talked about row as a return on ad
spend quite a bit
with any funnel they're going to be fall
off points or there's going to be
breaking points where you can identify
like is it the ads that aren't working
is it my sales page
should my more people be buying the
order bump so when you have this type of
system
the work comes into getting your ad
costs lower and like doing things to
optimize your audiences
and get the best ads running it's like a
teeter-totter where you're trying to get
your ad costs down and you're trying to
get your cart value up so as long as
your
average order value or your cost per
acquisition um
that's what the word is sorry for saying
the wrong one so if you can get your
average cost per acquisition or what it
costs to get a buyer
if you can get that lower than your
average cart value or how much
it ends up being when they buy you know
the average amount of people who buy the
first offer the second offer in the
third offer
as long as you can keep your ad costs
lower than what your
what your cart brings in then you're
going to be profitable so there's this
whole spreadsheet
that you can have that's um that helps
you figure out
which you know where you need to
optimize is it the sales page is it the
order bump
are the ads just too expensive like how
do you balance that teeter-totter and
make it happen
um like i said i celebrate the million
dollar
businesses as much as the first sale
because it's it's the beginning it's
really pivotal for people to see it
actually happen
this is megan she turned on her ads and
got her first sale she's so excited
um and then a coach inside of my program
was named jenny so she's thinking jenny
and the whole tiny offer family
that it was possible many tweaks to be
made
i don't like to leave that part out
because it is important that
it's not it's not always set it and
forget it right like it's marketing it
takes testing it takes trial and error
and she was saying she's excited that
she's done but she's optimistic even
though there's more work to be done
so just to recap this whole training uh
photo shoots and fancy websites don't
matter
the one thing that you need to stop
using freebies where most digital
product creators go wrong
that's not paying attention to what your
audience actually thinks they need
the four specific yes triggers every
product must have the exact no fluff
system i used to build this
in less than 30 days because i had to
so who does this work for anyone who has
an expert business who has a specialty
who is smart who has something to share
something to teach
and is willing to do the work uh anyone
who's good at what they do
again like energetically it shows if
you're not excited about what you're
selling
i've seen people build whole sales pages
and whole products and be like
meh i don't know we'll see what happens
and it never sells when people are like
this is the coolest thing i've ever
created then it always works so
really watching your energy behind what
you're creating if you're not excited
about it your audience probably isn't
going to be excited about it either
so anyone who's really thrilling ready
and willing i just invented a word
ready and willing to invest in
themselves and not just money but time
and self-belief as well
this is a client that i worked with
she's a in the decluttering niche
and she had never sold anything she
didn't even have a
whole big social media following i just
saw yesterday that she's got a
partnership with like i dive or idivine
products
because they saw her abs so sometimes
when you have ads running
you don't even know where sales are
going to come in you don't even know
where partnerships are going to be
created or where people are going to see
you
but having that visibility just cranking
all the time behind the scenes can turn
into opportunities that
you may have never had so if it doesn't
work
it's because you're not excited which
you know i can't say that
enough in enough different ways you have
to be excited about what you're creating
otherwise it'll show
if your system is broken and you're not
working to make it fix
or are not working to fix it or
if you launch it and it doesn't happen
and you're like whatever i failed
i give up that's the wrong attitude like
you want to
try things and like action is going to
help you
be successful much more quickly your
ability to move
from test to test at a fast rate will
help
or if you're not willing and ready
really
to invest time and money into your
system with leads um
time being like the blog posts or the
videos or anything that you're creating
you can always add this as a call to
action at the end like oh oh hey by the
way did you know that i just
created this product you can go grab it
for just 27 bucks you always have a call
to action and something to
start generating even if you're like
okay i just want proof
of concept before i run ads you can
totally do that you can totally start
there
otherwise if you're ready to invest in
ads you can just
you know get them up and running to the
sales page so it's really cool that you
can do it in two different ways
so i had launched this same funnel three
times um and i almost gave up just on
this funnel but because i had the
blinders on and my husband was like
you're gonna make this work because i
believe in you and i know you can do it
um
the secret was that it had to be the
easy button
so what i wanted to create what i wanted
to offer anyone who's here on this
training i created this product that's
called
the tiny offer toolkit and it's a tiny
offer about tiny offers which i know is
so meta but you can purchase it today
there's a special link for you guys
right there
and essentially it's all the templates
that i used and the easy buttons that i
was able to create for people
so i'm gonna show you that link so you
know what it looks like when you go
there can you see this
maybe you can't nope i think i need to
share a different screen if i wanted you
to see it
anyway if you go to that link you can
see
the different templates that i use
there's canva templates there's workbook
templates my calendar template that was
like the
the original offer that i created
um oh now you can see it thanks so this
is what you'll see on that page and it
is a tiny offer about tiny offers so you
can go grab that today as a special
offer
for being here on this training and and
being able to jump start
that you know creating them in 1 100th
of the time
because you have these templates so it's
got you know what goes into
creating a great tiny offer what goes
into optimizing the ads it's all within
this tiny offer toolkit that you see on
your screen
so that's everything that i have for the
training i'd love to hang out in
a tiny offer inception yes love to hang
out and answer any questions that you
guys have
without anything yeah ali first of all
thank you so much
absolutely incredible and just to frame
uh what we're about to uh get into
there's a lot still coming up
um but a few things that you need to
know in just a second we're going to end
this stream
over on our podcast channel and i just
want to thank you for being here smash
like if you got some value out of this
video
watch the replay of this i know it's
very dense it's very deeply strategic
um and you know if if you this was a
part of our inner circle program so we
just wanted to share this session
with you that are part of our think
media podcast community if you want to
learn more about that there's some links
in the description down below
uh it's called think inner circle i also
would just highly recommend
definitely check out uh
innercircletinyoffer.com
because this is a revolutionary
revolutionary
business system that ali has pioneered
i love her transparency this takes real
work you really got to tweak it
but she broke it all down in this
training and uh just such a great a
special
tiny offer super affordable to really
build a business
around your youtube channel and just a
second inner circle get your questions
in right now mel is going to be joining
us we're going to do some hot seats
and that's what our inner circle program
is every month if you actually want to
learn this kind of stuff
you know like facebook ads and
you know how to package your knowledge
in digital uh courses how to really
build your business out
when she put some of those funnel pages
up you might have been like oh my gosh
i feel like my brain is melting and i
don't know if your brain
hurts the same way that mine does but i
think about our journey
heather taurus myself us in the inner
circle community
it takes a while years to kind of wrap
your head around
these types of concepts to learn these
skill sets but the shortcut
is working with somebody who can shorten
your learning curve
just for people that want to go faster
that's what the inner circle tiny offer
is all about if you just want to go
faster
get the templates get uh the product
mockups the trello templates all the
different stuff
that is in here then definitely grab
that so again
uh you could see this
innercircletinyoffer.com
and um if you uh
smash like if you're on youtube and of
course
we will be back with the podcast back
with coffee with cannell and back with
everything else like that
um until then keep crushing it keep
smashing it and we will see you
in the next video and as we transition
the stream you can
click whatever end card we choose and
inner circle